ah il y a cinq ans à new york john
lennon était assassiné et d'ailleurs
scoop à la une va lui rendre un hommage
dans quelques instants
john lennon ne s'est pas contentée
d'ouvrir l'esprit des trois autres
beatles il a aussi fait avancer toute
une génération
parce qu'avant d'être un rockeur john
lennon était un poète
en france aussi on a eu des grands
poètes de la chanson on a eu brel
brassens ferré barbara mais quand on
voulait acheter quelque chose qui
swingue on était obligés d'acheter
anglais les beatles d'acheter américain
les beach boys ou d'acheter australien
les bee gees
c'était très difficile de trouver des
bonnes paroles qui en même temps soit
sur des musiques qui swingue et puis à
toute une bande de gens qui sont arrivés
des pionniers il ya eu claude nougaro
qui a mis des paroles formidable sur des
sons des classiques du jazz gainsbourg
qui a toujours fait paroles et musiques
jacques dutronc avec lanzmann bien
entendu et puis un québécois charlebois
avec en 1969 sa fameuse chanson
lindbergh et puis d'un seul coup il ya
un personnage qui a débarqué dans la
chanson française
un type qui ressemble un peu à starsky
mais enfin qui a plutôt l'âme de woody
allen qui chante comme il dit des trucs
qui swingue mais qui sont pas débiles et
puis moi je crois que si aujourd'hui le
président mitterrand peut dire à la
télévision qu'il est chez brand c'est
sans doute un peu grâce à mon invité
d'aujourd'hui je vous présente alain
souchon
bonjour tu sais je sais je trouve ta
présentation flatteuse et bien livré sa
vérité pour moi bien agréable alors ça
va mais oui tu as vu le public c'est ce
que je dirai non moi je trouve qu'avec
des choses comme je suis bidon maman
bobo etc
jamais contents vous avez trouvé des
mollahs qui se mélangent peut-être un
peu au vocabulaire de la pub au
vocabulaire de la rue et qui crée une
nouvelle langue et ça fait vraiment
avancer la langue je suis tout à fait
sincère quand je dis ça aide mais c'est
vrai que quand on est arrivé avec voulzy
on voulait que faire des paroles qui
dise où on sent qu'il ya un peu
quelqu'un un homme un peu derrière les
chansons et puis en même temps il
fallait un peu brisé le langage pour que
ça swingue quoi alors on a fait ça mais
c'est une c'est très important ce parce
que la chanson comme la pub comme le
langage de la rue fait avancer les
choses et c'est très important alors par
contre vous sortez un nouveau disque qui
s'appelle comme on voulait je les
écoutais n'est pas mal simplement il ya
un truc qui m'a beaucoup étonné ouais
c'est que toutes les musiques ne sont
pas de voulzy
alors est ce que nous allons faire un
coup à l'aller l'aude macartney là est
ce que vous allez vous disputer non on
se dispute pas comme ça non
non mais déjà l'album d'avant et avec
une seule chanson j'avais fait avec
laurent et là y en a cinq
ce parce que il fait après on a
travaillé pour lui le pij adore
travailler avec louis chedid michel
curio david maintenait moi j'aime bien
faire les chansons à deux ça fait comme
un jeu de société de tout seul je me
mets au piano ça fait des trucs lugubre
lui il ya une chose qui vous avez quand
même toujours ce côté un peu un peu
triste comme ça ça vous a permis de
réussir ça vous est servi à réussir mais
est-ce que vous êtes maintenant
prisonniers de la tristesse humains
martic inventrice dans la vie on fait
des chansons comme ça sur un peu ce
qu'on ressent j'aime toute façon j'aime
les chansons tristes
oui même les chansons qu'on appelle gay
que traditionnellement en france on
chante à la fin des banques est même au
18e siècle les marches du palais ou je
sais pas quoi c'était des chansons
d'amour triste
les belles chansons souvent
rist quoi les chansons john lennon
s'était jamais youplaboum tralala you
pas vraiment mais vous avez fait une
chanson sur lennon qui s'appelle lennon
kaput non lennan capote valls et c'était
quoi les paroles les caresser les
béziers par disent qu'on volait dans les
années soixante dix abandonnés dans les
camions le long des routes n'en parlons
plus des jabots en laine capote
dans tous les cas on vous aime assez
sachez qu'en vous aime tous c'est ça que
je veux avant tout seul alors maintenant
on va passer au jeu on va demander après
nos amis de faire d une à partir des
images
alors là bas